i have a pair of my glasses that i got
at oliver people's and i both could buy
like two or three of them so i had these
black ones you know i went to go see him
at the greek years ago and uh
the kind of caesar where so i go i
caesar i try these on he goes oh these
are nice and so those are the ones that
jay-z wears so jay-z where's his daddy
bees uh all of her people's and he goes
oh these are nice i go you can have them
it was what for reals because you know
then they go i go yeah i mean they just
look perfect on them and then he goes
miha these are the ones jc wears
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg hi oh my god hi
about five o'clock
they came and told me they said hey you
know we've had two emergencies yours is
not scheduled till at least 8 50 and
we're not even sure if it's going to go
then what the [ __ ] is there only one
[ __ ] doctor working this was the
valve specialist the heart guy they
called it another surgeon even to help
him out the procedure took so long they
brought him in they saved his life at
least for the night so my procedure
was just going to be
pushed back a little bit i mean they
wanted whatever they said well that
nurse came out and they said hey listen
a couple emergencies came in
one guy is severe i mean we we
we had to stop his heart restart it
that's what they had to do with this guy
and uh okay well then i'm on the right
path yeah and then
we were in there and we found that they
had a little baby heart attached to the
regular heart we took that one out
it's right now it's it's in a [ __ ]
hamster in lancaster the hamster is
still alive
we're gonna bring it back
friday
from three to five put it in a person
lochinito probably that person's gonna
live
so we have to put you on the back burner
okay then you open the door to the
doctor's office they're both in there
like that
did you [ __ ] believe it or not
they could tell you anything and we
believe it
well they could there are good people
that say
uh
remember that guy did you watch the
thing on netflix uh
he's like a uh
curandero from like from brazil no no
i don't think so you wake up with his
[ __ ] dick on your arm man
you're like what the [ __ ] he puts you to
sleep and then you wake up you're like
ah you're healthy i watched that other
one you told me about that grandma
you're like what the [ __ ] kind of church
is this i watch that you're speaking to
that i watch that other one you're
talking about about the octopus
oh yeah
what do you think what the hell is that
what do you think of that is it that was
some amazing thing that that that's
fascinating stuff i once i started
watching i said i'm sitting there saying
i was [ __ ] up well i'm gonna watch
this and then it just kind of sucks you
in you keep watching and watching
watching it and it was almost sad when
they had to leave you know he didn't
even leave a phone number or nothing
i don't know if they made love they were
holding hands in the water
at high tide
great you see it you saw it i know it's
the wildest thing yeah
that an octopus that i guess that guy
did he lose his son or something
somebody died that
and he he was kind of lost and he always
had been into like diving and stuff so
he started to dive and then
he saw this octopus
and they started [ __ ] dating on them
how was someone who hasn't seen it how
did they actually octopus have like a
thousand little octopus babies and then
they put one under the microscope but
had exactly the same eyes as i do
[Laughter]
check the
dna
there's some cows out there that
remember we talked about that i'm born
with people's heads there's some [ __ ]
going on man
um yeah
i don't know what happened to oscar
other than
you know
seeing him here and seeing him look good
sweating yeah he was drinking just
coffee yeah and then uh what was it
wednesday maybe that he had it and i i
looked on instagram and
i think friday
he was in the hospital which already
tells you that it's
that severe yeah he looked and he looked
bad
so um
he was unshaven
laying down
the lighting was poor but what's what's
going on man we're like what's happening
with all that and he was vaccinated too
right
it was a breakthrough sort of case
[Music]
i've been hearing that if it's like
maybe as far as like the boosters go it
seems like after five five months seems
to be something of like a cut-off point
where they're starting to see more
people get
breakthrough cases okay so
as uh
as people of you know wherever they
podcast of
of the world
you're gonna stick you see people yeah
that one right there
you see people wearing uh
masks
going into a store
and uh
they're all touching the doorknob
without gloves
i mean isn't that putting that risk if
you go to they're all touching money and
changing
i think it's it's mostly and i haven't
been on top of this i should have been
but i think it's mostly because it's
like it's aerosolized or it's it's like
particles in the air basically like i
remember early on in the pandemic it was
like oh
um you know be careful with the food
wipe down everything you touch etc and
still you know always good like wash
your hands on that thing but i think as
far like the mask the hand stuff is
gonna be way less effective than
the mask stuff the old uh homicide cop
that i am it says when it's your time
it's your time mm-hmm i'll give a [ __ ]
that's what you guys believe yeah i i
believe that you know you when it's your
time
i just somebody up there just says okay
352 today it's his time
my grandma used to say if it's your time
it's your time um
genetics
people get sick as a kid you know as a
you know i've seen a lot of people that
have been sick um
because of my own kidney thing you know
but like you know of kids that are sick
and then they're saying hey can you go
to the hospital and talk to this kid you
know or go see this kid
uh you know kid kids were
born with like
leukemia and and stuff like that that
don't even live a year i mean yeah
that's tough
it's tough that those are those are
tough hated kid cases i
kids
are terrible it's your time i remember i
bought a motorcycle
i had a harley and my mom was saying
ho you know you're going to fall by and
i said mom when it's your time it's your
time
look at i was just a couple of weeks ago
at cerritos air crash disaster and i
said people having a barbecue in their
backyard
they had no idea plane was going to land
and wipe out the whole family in the
house it was their time you know
they were doing nothing wrong
i asked my partner ray verdugo
i said how much time do you think you
know we're out there looking at this
disaster i said how much time do you
think the passenger had
on that idle vehicle
from the time they impacted the time
they landed
how long they must have been he looked
up and he looked down he looked at me
and he says ah about enough time for
three iii's and two ideos meals yeah
[Laughter]
i mean
we're coming on the 20 years of 9 11.
yeah there's a lot of documentaries out
there there's one on uh
national geographic history channels
like like six of them six different
episodes and uh
i was asked to be a guest speaker uh
for 9 11.
saturday
for the vfw
and uh it's coincidence because i was
asked to speak at muhammad's daughter's
uh quinceanera no
but i can't yes i can't be there i'll
come he'll be at the quinceanera i'm
gonna be uh
flying back from dallas i leave for
dallas tomorrow
wait a minute where are you going to be
in dallas i'm going over there to be a
speaker
at a dallas conference for saturday
no i'm leaving tomorrow i speak
on thursday or friday
but i don't come my flight doesn't come
back till saturday
and it doesn't it doesn't uh
land until 11 30 and
that'll be done with over there at the
bfw it's morning thing did it move it
for you pardon me no no they they had
already sent out the schedule they sent
a flyer they
they did everything and they just wanted
me to dress
because it's a veteran but it's really
i think for 9 11 to remember them and so
since i've had both sides of the fence
they wanted me
uh to be there for them
well
you're gonna be speaking tomorrow the
way i heard on the news big boys big
boys uh yeah hollywood star yeah
cool yeah you know the uh there's
testing there too you have to make sure
that you know you're
tested uh
and good for it but also won't let you
in
inside in the vicinity of that
absolutely yeah i have no problem with
with testing i have no problem with any
of it i don't panic over any of it i
don't get scared you know i don't get to
touch that touch this [ __ ] if i touch
myself i'll touch anything
we're all negative too right so everyone
knows everyone tested negative we're all
good yeah even though oscar was here
spraying his [ __ ] germs everywhere
through his coffee
he was weird when he just started
spitting everywhere that was
it's a good thing
for flags they would spread those germs
all over the place just the idea that
consumers probably probably put them in
the air
hey do you know do you know what these
are for do you know what this is
somebody told me this you know what this
is
it's a frisbee if you are not if you
haven't finished drinking the beer you
put it on you put it in your
refrigerator and it doesn't go flat why
not
huh oh that's genius where's that hop
core is light
[ __ ] up
hey so that's it the guy says i put that
thing on and it
doesn't let the beer go flat i said what
thing the
folder yeah you mean those black
little plastic circles
put it on like that yeah those things
are
i've like discovered so many things
about those they've got the handle built
in in the middle which took me a while
to find they've got you resealable like
you're doing you can take it off put it
back on
it's uh that's some high technology you
got
i like to take credit for it
like i don't know what it is but i'm
gonna want to know
but we used to just put a uh
napkin and yeah right
and they go hey even if that soda was in
there for seven years you couldn't have
another soda till you finished drinking
that one and then it would go flat so
you were essentially drinking [ __ ]
black olive juice
because they wouldn't make you get
another flat
you know so what else is going on
speaking about
one more thing about oscar yeah i gotta
tell you i watch i don't watch all the
shows you know we do them you know
they're here
uh what show did you watch oscars
this year this show jordan lopez only
got high oh yeah and i watched the show
it's different when you watch it than if
you're then yeah right yeah but i
laughed just as hard watching the show
you know i did when i was here
it's legit because we were inside a long
time ago and i could see my i could see
my face when you said okay watch it he's
going to cry right now when i start
talking about that i can see the look on
my face hardy going oh
yeah it was a good show oscar yeah thank
you yeah jeff wilker thank you um
you know it's fascinating man because
it's never as simple as just somebody
just having to do
their job like oscar didn't want to
fight i didn't know that
yeah i didn't i didn't know that then he
said he was sexually abused
which i didn't want to get into here
because it's so close to the fight you
know yeah sure i i
you don't want to
i didn't bring him here to question
about being sexually abused but
you know um but i didn't know that
either myself so that was but then his
father being tough and his mother
passing away
and his mother was hard on him too i
remember the interview i remember fred
rogan i remember the uh when he won the
fight
i was watching it back but
and and i'm not blowing smoke up you but
you never cease to amaze me
you must do
nothing all goddamn day but look and
study history
the
the historical facts that you know about
in this case about oscar yeah about
criminals about this
you know how do i know that [ __ ]
medic
talking about that
you know i used to think i was a good
fight fan but
damn i'm sitting here listening to you
and then they're just so it's amazing
how i and and
i you know
i don't study it or anything i think it
just comes
around or sometimes on the phone you can
look it up like that but um
not easy for oscar because even you
think you win the gold medal
what about
he got his ass kicked by that guy from
germany remember his ass kicked before
yeah that would have scared the [ __ ] out
of me as he said he walked underneath
him oh my
he's looking around he's kicking
everybody's ass and then he's like
where's germany yeah he said like
where's the guy from germany and it was
the guy that he was going to fight yeah
that was awesome and that's
that that could put a lot of guys out
just just that you know i went back and
watched it again because i'd seen it
before
the press conference and the fight
between him and my orga
and
it was awesome you know knowing the
background on it you know again
listening what he said here it was it
was all around but also you know like he
said you know like um
from tuesday on you can't be around
anybody because you're you're
essentially like a wild animal like a
racehorse yeah in the pen or whoever's
around you big sweet
um i think you
i mean i don't know what the everybody's
routine is but you probably sleep you
don't really work out a lot but you got
to do a little cardio and then
at the weigh-in
you get like the pacquiao weigh-in he
took his robe off and he looked
incredible like the way he said the
other guy looked ripped he looked like
that
but nobody knew he was dehydrated
because he had gotten to the weight
maybe a month early
and he got there too early
and then he had to try to keep the
weight off and he was dehydrated
so when he took his robe off and he went
like that he was he was chiseled
and then when he got into the ring
he had
like flab on his belly and his back
and it was from the hydration and eating
that he just put on
13 20 pounds maybe in a day
it's happened to me to stuff people
right yeah uh so that was not um
a good fight i didn't know that he felt
like he had been forced to retire
yeah i didn't know that i just thought
that was a
tough fight and that maybe it was you
know his time but nothing in his life
seemed easy even from
starting the fight
to losing his mother and the gold medal
and all that stuff and then through
you know not being considered
mexican enough
by the mexicans and then beating
chavez twice and the second time he said
he beat him
i think the most
one of the most interesting turns is
chavez
which makes you really happy about a guy
like that finally found
somewhere
and even the place he's trained to be
clean and to help other people be clean
because sure was otherwise he'd be dead
pretty he'd be dead yeah
he'd be dead but that's i mean you know
he was going to fight i'm not sure i
haven't talked to him if he's going to
continue maybe to fight later i think
holyfield has taken his
his uh yes holyfield they've announced
it
oh really yeah i didn't see a whole
phil's going to fight was belfort who he
was going to fight yeah sounds like it
yeah okay that's a good fight
then would holyfield fight oscar
i don't know
that's
that's a tough one i think fighting this
got to be the toughest
i can't imagine i just can't imagine
as a detective you do you get shot you
never got shot at by a criminal right
you guys usually come in when it's over
yeah when i get there he's dead
my day begins when there's ends
right that's right um
and then so
let's say something happened i mean
okay a couple of things happened this
last week or so momo
uh and thank god you know he eats every
hour you know small meals
uh but he was at the haha cafe and those
comedians that unfortunately there were
four of them oh yeah and then three
passed and then the girl the girl lived
and it lived but uh the girl
said to a woman you know can i go on
ahead of you because i'm gonna go with
these guys they went to venice and they
got
uh coke with fennel in it yeah yeah
um
what's the investigation of that
what are the so you go over there i mean
that had to be quite a sight man to see
people oh dean i i don't know what
happened you probably throw up or
convulsing well you're gonna look around
yeah you know ods usually have frothy
mouth you know they they get froth
coming out of their mouths
yeah you're going to look around
and if there's no signs of violence you
know no no
nothing disruptive nothing's out of the
ordinary well then you got to think okay
you're thinking
possibly od
so when you think possibly od then you
got to do victim final hate
that these guys use drugs you know where
they into drugs you know you got to find
out their victimality what they're about
and then
if there's no other because you go in it
looking at it as a murder
okay but you're eliminating why it's not
a murderer okay i don't see acts of
violence i don't see a break-in i don't
see any defensive wounds you have to
leave there's any left on the table or
any other i don't see any of this is
there debris what you're talking about
left over on the table is there any
packets any of this any that
and
then once you get to that determination
if there's no other explanation
obvious to you
well then you wait for a toxicology and
then talks will come back and tell you
if it is an od or not
and then
depending on how far they want to take
it you know if there's some evidence
that comes up right away
where did the dope come from can an odb
case closed if it comes back yeah and
they od and
you're just like okay well they od yeah
the only one that i've ever seen
prosecuted that went beyond just an od
was john belushi i was gonna say yeah
john belushi's uh was oh what happened
there well they got the girl they gave
me the shot kathy smith smith
smith's last name that
that gave him the the juice and and
that's what that's what happened they
prosecuted her that's the only one that
i've seen yeah that uh
to my recollection
they were together like they were out
together that night him and a few other
well uh
well-known people richard pryor was one
of them and they were at the comedy
store and then he left no did richard
bryan use dope
occasionally
there's rumors
yeah
uh on occasion you know as a pick-me-up
you know long days on the set
um but brilliant comedian though really
troubled again uh but uh let's see
correlation here coalition yeah and then
uh yeah she went
she went to prison
um
did she like knowingly give him
was bad bad drugs or bad no no
it was
i don't remember it was another one in
cocaine yeah but i don't it may have
just been an overdose yeah too much i i
really don't remember the facts i
remember i was working homicide at the
time
because we screwed with our team
lieutenant
i wasn't part of it but the guys
called him up and said hey we had you
know pretending to be a news station
he was at home
called him up said hey we'd like a
statement you know on the murder of john
blue she says hey that wasn't my case
well we have you down is making a
statement yesterday and
he says you don't understand and they
said no we do what do you want us to say
your name is down here and says i got
nothing to say hung up and he called the
bureau and he saw pissed off he says who
in the hell is giving out my name yet
so the lieutenant that was on duty there
called the guys at the code seven which
was the local bar down the street
at first in los angeles called them up
and said
okay guys stop [ __ ] with them that's
what it was called code seven yeah it's
called the code still
uh no it's it's gone and that's where
the new police department
they should have just left it in there
like a food court they even had a
sandwich in there named after me they
did that yeah it was the team team gil
creo team three it was roast beef cheese
uh ortega chili's the whole chili's on
there grill
grilled oh it was good
wow it was real good yeah that's a
pretty good one that sounds great was
that like an order that you got a lot or
did they just name one after you they
they named i i loved it so much when
they redid their menu this and then
we're gonna name it after you oh that's
all that really ultimately on it
what was it
they're from the counter taker or they
these probably
it just it wasn't a lot it's a long
yeah but it's not a jalapeno chip what
is that no no it's just
it would be like yeah it's it's long
kind of like over here they call them
anime anaheim chilies
green chili ortega or
i just i almost sent you a picture you
could have seen a picture of me the
other day i roasted two 25 pound boxes
of hatch chili from new mexico there you
go hatch yeah that that's that's the
best of them
is with the cheese
cheese inside the inside of it and then
dip it in egg and then they fry it
that's that's pretty good oh they're the
bomb
they're the you know what they make a
good one my favorite
at marios tacos where we brought the
burritos in that day yeah they make a
good one
i'll stop by next time i come in have
you been over there at stephen
steakhouse since we talked last night
yeah yeah yeah
the other day yeah i was just there the
other day and what's going on with it
steven steakhouse is doing they're alive
and well they're doing good i met some
guy there
uh no vietnam buddy
of mine well buddy i hadn't seen him
since vietnam
and he's got a son
uh that lives in west hollywood he's
quadriplegic this guy lives back in
michigan but his son wants to be
independent he's doing well you know he
comes out here he picked 24-hour care
for him he wants to be on his own he
wants to be able to go places do stuff
so he says hey i'm gonna be out there
for a few days how about let's hook it
up i
haven't seen him from vietnam so we went
to stephen's steakhouse
and then friday when they shut me down
from uh yeah my heart procedure
my daughter said
we better go get something good to eat
and i said okay let's go to stephen's
statement oh because you had you had to
uh fast yeah i had to pass so i hadn't
had since six o'clock the morning not
even water across my lips and it's now
six o'clock in the evening that's let's
go to stevens i can give me a glass of
wine nice steak
it was good so when's it when's the
procedure scheduled for now they're
supposed to call me up today and
reschedule it and it can't be this week
because i'm gonna be out of town but
it'll be the next week
and you feel you feel okay just yeah the
way you are but yeah when that's done
you're gonna feel a lot better exactly
exactly
so
i'm looking forward i'm i'm excited i
just want to get it done yeah
yeah man that's it's um
crazy times right now huh the 9 11 so
okay so the comedians there
um yeah that one girl is in there
ah man i mean that's that [ __ ] is
they're cutting it with phenomenon
this fenelon came out
long after i was a cop but it's supposed
to be some nasty stuff you know people
are od left and right over there it's
crazy just like ten thousand times more
effective than other i guess opioids or
something like whatever it is yeah they
can manufacture
themselves it's crazy yeah is it super
concentrated yeah it's like a tiny pill
but it's like
and that that's what they suspect
michael k williams passed away from as
well yes omar from the wire he passed
yesterday two days yesterday was that
heroin or was that it was his heroine he
would he had been i think they said he
had been using he knew he had an
addiction knew he had a problem and he
was using cocaine
that's pretty sad man
this stuff is out there it's killing
people
coast to coast and it's it's rough i
think a lot of people too bring a lot of
like judgment to people who die like
that's like oh just goes to show you
don't do drugs something sort of simple
like that but it always feels i don't
know to me it always rings way more
tragic than that as long as they're not
ripping me off burglarizing they they do
what they got to do it doesn't affect me
yeah so i think with him they were
trying to pursue
um
the person that may have given it to him
and and now with with these community
you're the first guy i thought of and
and i didn't even think about momo at
first and then i looked at that last
picture
uh one of the pictures of a poster
recently momo's way in the back and i
made some comment it looks
bigger in the in the mirror you know oh
yeah yeah and and so
uh
how does this affect
the comedic
world you know his friends you know you
knew these guys
i didn't know them personally but
i think
i think there might have been owners or
friends of the people that own the haha
cafe
the day that you came in here after the
anniversary of uh
kobe
you were visually affected you know you
were sad and i could being around you
you know it was a tough it was a little
harder than your
regular day
uh
but i i just didn't know if it affected
you with
these people in the comedic world um
yeah not i don't know man i mean you
know it's a pretty it's not it's kind of
not a close community right
i mean it's i don't know if it's ever
been yeah yeah you you tell me right
a long time i don't think it's a close
community
i think that um
you know there's some people that are
friends and some people that there were
a lot of them in vegas last week and
that i was there like jokoy was over
there and then those guys
were out there in maz giobrani and then
those guys but uh you know even reuben
like rumors with me
it's a different show you go you come to
the backstage there's nobody in there
very few people so i think over there
those guys are used to maybe more uh
camaraderie than what i have because
i've been doing it for so long that you
do the show and
kind of lock it down have a couple of
drinks relax and then go back to the
room because it's like what are you
gonna try to prove and
yeah in one night if anything it just
feels like it gets a little longer you
get time to deliver any tacos when you
were over there you know what i did not
man that thing fell through
but the tacos are doing good for grub or
next bite so yeah i did yeah
keep buying my honor i hope she listens
to this podcast next week because she
keeps telling me oh dad i went and
bought all the cardinal sata they had at
the store
i bought them out i bought about 10
packs that's all they had left until
they get some more in and so now
officially on record i hope she
understands that her dad likes that
stuff maybe she could
you know
cut out cut a package for her dad right
yeah you'd think
can take the gun outside was pretty good
man i got in by arthur restaurants it's
it's uh that was a tough one
um
to get into but they you know the prices
are you know it's like momo keeps uh
track of the price of cotton like gold
right now
is up
you know i keep track of it every day
you know
that like you know like gold you're
you're you're you came out at the right
time it's like the market is dipping so
i see opportunity here
so we'll have to see what um
transpires and all this stuff but you
know yeah it's a part of uh
of these things that i mean
prince you know i knew prince that was
that was uh
fenelon related
because you know he had a hip
replacement
and he was really you know very
i mean elusive elusive character kind of
but
you know
in that time i'm not sure i think it's
gotten better but
if you got a hip replacement you had to
go back in there at least one or two
times to go and get a tweak because it's
not something that
you went in there and they did right the
first time oh really paul stanley you
know kiss had uh his hip replaced and
had to go in a couple times maybe have a
couple procedure and last half and
half an inch on that leg
so
as a performer you'd have to put like a
half an inch spacer in the shoe or the
boot and now to balance them out but he
went in there you know the legs were the
same length and then came out then there
was one happening shorter
so i mean what i think they've gotten
better at it but
it took a little maintenance and i think
he didn't want to do that
and he was trying to kind of
self-medicate or herself you know kind
of take the pain away yourself yeah he
better hope that doctor was
self-medicating man before they went
into surgery if he's back in that room
going
it's hard it's hard to trust anybody now
you know
before you would be concerned with what
the doctor's credentials are and now
there's people that are doctors and
they're in [ __ ] shopping centers man
they're
you know you know the the good thing is
with my procedure
the lady that they came to advise her
her
husband had done
he's still alive you know done good
didn't hit her knee okay and but that
doctor
was the same doctor
and this it was his valve that was
messed up so the same doctor do my
procedure was working on him and he had
another emergency back to back so i'm
sitting there saying the back of my mind
too
i don't maybe i don't want this doctor
after he's done too certain like right
some get some rest right right right
i think that that's good i'm thinking
there's probably some things that 10
hours at a time so yeah
something you want to do let's just wait
until you're well rested yeah would you
look up fenelon uh yeah i looked it up i
was curious about it the
when did it how long has it been out
uh let's see so it was originally made
because it's a synthetic chemical in
1960 and was approved for medical use
1968.
and it's just been slowly going up since
then but only
uh only recently has it been the big
sort of like um illegal drug overdose
drug and has since 2016 been the most
common cause of overdose deaths more
than 20 000 of opioid related deaths
which is about half so about 40 thousand
dollars
and it's much easier to get uh i believe
it too you get on the street
on the street they're cutting it with it
they're cutting cocaine with it yeah the
last line of the the wikipedia summary
says compared to heroin it's more potent
has higher profit margins and because
it's compact has simpler logistics can
be cut into or even replace entirely the
supply of heroin and other opiates which
is the perfect
thing to go wrong in every every
situation
man that's
what's going on with that
yeah i think you think the pandemic has
anything to do with people using or or
out of boredom
why would you want to i've definitely
read that like rates of whatever have
gone up over the past you know 18 months
people just trying to cope
i don't know because i don't i don't
think like them you know i gotta think
otherwise so i don't know what their
what's going through their mind
the
devil's workshop was an idle mind so if
you got an idle mind you know you may do
stuff that you wouldn't want to do
normally
yeah i mean is it
not me i mean are you saying i found
myself drinking more wine during the
pandemic i think it's good for you yeah
i think that's anything that can relax
you but that you know
uh
wanted to back off of of extinguishing
your your your light in there
but all of that stuff and then i think
after the drug dealer for michael k
williams i think they're going to try to
find that yeah
well they also found the drug dealer for
the angels the supplier they're going
after him the angel baseball player that
lost his life they're going after him oh
really yeah he was part of the staff
well he was part of the staff yeah he
was in the locker room there he was part
of the locker room staff at bro that's a
violation
man
you always got to know somebody where
you can get the stuff from but i mean
yeah you don't you don't want it to
damage anybody but
uh
different uh
different times for sure that [ __ ]
and even i don't know
do people do younger people just do it
just to do it to have fun do they go to
vegas and are they
i mean they call them recreational drugs
for a reason right i don't know i don't
run in those circles you know i don't
know i don't know anybody that does you
know so it's hard for me to
say it's hard for me to judge
i know you see people uh i get concerned
when i see people that are acting
angry they're paranoid they're this or
that you know that's that's a good
indicator there's something else going
on
well i think if um
we live in these times where
even your neighbors i mean i don't know
any of my neighbors i don't want to know
my neighbors
they're you know they might have
mistaken me a couple weeks ago for not
living in my house that's not good like
every everything that
a neighborhood used to be is to me it's
not anymore like you love thy neighbor
treat your neighbor as you would treat
your your for yourself your family yeah
just a lot of people out there concerned
about other people's business sure um
[Music]
you know even in pet adoption you know
where that girl in here that people are
returning their dogs or even returning
them or letting them go
because of
of what's going on it's on the news
right now that they're having problems
with them and i i want to say i don't
know if it's the county or somebody
adoption age is now starting
they're going to evaluate whether
exactly if he needs to come back well
they're just going to [ __ ] let them
go and grip and park like an old man
you know they're trying to take them
back with some dignity and they go like
oh well you know we evaluated that you
know you you
you you can watch this dog all right
and then
man what do we have do you have voice
mails and all that oh yeah we got some
foreign
hey but she is welcome anytime
out in training pit put that in training
good
let's see
oh also gil was telling me off mike a
crazy story about a michael mann
movie that he worked on i wanted to
bring i don't know if you wanted to sure
if you want to recount it this was
fascinating this is michael mann during
the movie heat oh yeah yeah i was uh did
you work on heat yeah i worked on he
worked on eight and uh showing him how
to do some interviews so they wanted me
to sit down supposed to be myself and my
old partner gilpara
gilpara was sick he was fighting cancer
at the time so they said gil you go in
there and we'll get a captain that's out
here as a friend of michael mann he's a
captain from chicago pd
you and him do this interview
and i'm saying michael chicago works
different we
we don't put hands on people over here
they put hands on people and he said no
it'll work out it'll work out
he brought with him
his wise guy friend guy was a wise guy
back in chicago
so we're sitting down there and i
started asking him you know we're doing
an interview they're filming it you got
actors you got pacino y'all watching
they're all watching right there michael
t
and so i started asking this guy
question he says you lead the questions
i start asking a guy question but he
he's playing hardball he's playing like
an old con you know what's your name
bobby
bobby do you have a last name yeah well
what is it smith where do you live on
the east side
you know not giving me answers that i
want so he's playing hardball
so i had had that day
i had a buddy of mine bobby tucson
covering an autopsy for me but it was a
simple autopsy was a gunshot wound
through and through to the head
so i said i'm going to go over here i
got to do this bobby would you cover the
autopsy for me says no problem
so we're sitting there and i'm talking
and the captain realizes that this guy
from chicago is being a wise guy being
an [ __ ]
so he just reaches up and slaps him
across the face
hard
just reaches up [ __ ] bam
and just saying my beepers going off
because we see beepers back then pagers
so my pager's going off and i saw i said
i said excuse me gents i'll be right
back i gotta answer this page so i got
up when i walked away from the table
there was a phone public phone on the
wall behind us so i go back there and i
call the guy up
i said hey bobby you called he says yeah
i just just like you called it you know
the autopsy and then all of a sudden you
hear this ah
screaming going on he says gil where are
you at what's going on give me an
address i said no no bobby i'm on a
movie set don't worry everything's okay
and
he says okay well just like you said it
was gonna be any and then you hear this
blood curdling scream worse than the
first one
he says gil give me an address we'll
send the cops down there i'll be rolling
right now yet
and then you hear michael matt saying
okay cut cut gut
and i said you see bobby it was just
it's pull it's movie stuff not me too he
[ __ ] had him down on the ground
he had a
he had his balls
in his hand and he says [ __ ] you
got something i want and i got something
you want
now i want the information in your
[ __ ] head right now
and then he gives him another
twist and he got blood curly scream he
says michael man this is okay cut cut
cut that was good that was good
and uh it was
it was impressive then i interviewed uh
danny trejo in that movie danny was one
of the bad guys yep and danny as we know
did time in the joint
he's a dropout so
danny's right there i start interviewing
him
all of a sudden i just tell him you know
he's not coming across real good and i
told him he's
you see a pee on my forehead do you see
a tattoo of a pee and he says no i said
that's because i'm not a pendejo i said
you're going back to where you came from
when i'm done with you
it treats you like a little shyla in
there this guy starts sweating
michael man says cut
danny looks at me says ching go i
haven't felt like that
for years man i felt like i was back in
it all again you were sweating the [ __ ]
out of me
and that was all part of just
of just the prep yeah so they could see
what it was like to interview people
and uh al pacino nice guy give me a hug
he says god damn you're great you know i
said well
not great that just that's the job
i do this for a living you act i do that
for a living wow
so it was pretty cool but there is a way
to cut through the [ __ ] if somebody
trying to stall a police officer out
sure you're not gonna be able to stall a
cop out yeah if you're good you can they
know the answer already before they're
asking oh sure yeah
sure
the uh yeah yeah you don't want to ask a
question you don't know the answer
right well you know danny you know i
met danny and noah for a while and he
said that when they were doing heat they
went into a restaurant i don't want to
say the restaurant because it could
still be something that you know and uh
danny was acting in the restaurant and
he he's looking around he's like
he's like [ __ ] i think we
we robbed this place
before well you know back in the day
we went into a restaurant during the
shooting movie we they called it want to
have dinner
and it was myself and two other homicide
cops by partner gil par and a guy named
ray bardugo and we go down there
and we're having dinner at this
restaurant and
they just want to see how we interact
because these guys can be cops so
we're talking we're telling stories
telling jokes
and then michael t that's the guy that
came out as bubba gump and then he tells
me he tells a story about when he was in
georgia because that's where they filmed
a lot of the movie
he says we're down there he says one day
after a long day of shooting he says
getting ready to leave i see some extra
they've been there all day and you know
he's having a car trouble
and so i just walked i said hey
now you need to ride i give you a ride
back in town you want the guy says oh
would you and he says yeah he says come
on okay and then the guy runs back to
his car real quick
he forgot a bag she got the bag and
gotten tired inside michael t's car and
he started driving
and michael t says he keeps noticing the
guy keeps opening up the bag and looking
inside
finally michael t says
hey partner you don't mind me asking it
must be something important what you got
in the bag there
he says the guy looked at me and said
none of your business
he says i slammed on the [ __ ]
break so get the [ __ ] out of my car
right now [ __ ] eat your own
right the guy steps out of the car
michael he punches
it the guy left the bag inside the car
oh and so he drove away
and i said no [ __ ] he left the bag
inside the car and i said did you ever
look inside he says yeah i did i said
what was inside he says none of your
business [ __ ]
he didn't tell you oh dude great [ __ ]
it was just a joke oh it was a joke he
just reeled me in and when you asked oh
yeah yeah yeah none of your business
[ __ ] classic it was a great joke
that's fantastic well you know i uh
in keeping with that
i
know a
ex-athlete
that the time of the o.j
simpson
alleged double homicide
that
a girl
that was allegedly involved with o.j
simpson ended up with that louis vuitton
suitcase
and she had it at her house and then she
knew this ex-football player and she
asked if he could keep it
at his house until they needed it
and he said yes so he kept it in his
garage i think he was in the garage for
two years
and i said you ever look inside of the
thing he said never
because i put it in the garage and put
it on the shelf
and i tried to pretend it wasn't there
but i looked out it looked insane that's
tough to pretend it's not there no funny
that's the most infamous piece of
evidence oh my god i mean it came back
from chicago i thought it came back with
anything in there maybe
i mean that's stuff you can't
close or
i mean a weapon i mean
you think he did that thing at the
airport
i had no idea where he ditched it what
he did with it i just
there's no doubt in my mind as to his
innocence or guilt
and and
the only thing i want to clarify you
said the two alleged homicides there was
no allies oh yeah it was they were they
were different they were demonstrating
yeah they were yeah yeah the homicide
involvement yeah
that's just a definition a homicide is
just a definition of death at the hands
of another so so
as you get you know as we get further
away from an event you know there's more
factual information comes out i think
people are more ready to be truthful and
there's one on o.j that is either on the
history channel or discovery
and uh
a guy that he knows says in the
documentary so if she hadn't have
answered the door with a knife in her
hand
she'd still be alive
and that he said
most likely yes
i think i think somebody you know when
it's like you go over to somebody's
house and they got a baseball bat in
their hand and you're like what the [ __ ]
you got the bat for i mean i don't know
what you want
you're like i don't you don't know what
i want and then it turns you into yeah
it turns into an adversarial start
things on that note yeah
right i think you've seen it um
i'm glad it was my case can people get
away with murder these days
very tough very tough and the biggest
giveaway is they talk everybody talks
right whether it be
to your homeboy who you'd love or he'll
die take it to his grave they don't take
[ __ ] to their group
what uh well police procedure that i
think is brilliant is they put an
informer in the cell either with the guy
or
on the cell next door right the guys
want to talk they talk to yeah they're
talking to another people and now social
media
yeah forget it yeah they talk on social
media they do a lot so it's it's tough
to get away
with it today and manson the susan
adkins
was in a uh in the cell with a woman
that was like i think
she was an actress but she kind of like
like a prostitute and then
she told her
and that woman was doing you know and
even as an older woman she was still
very attractive you know yes so she had
some information and she said call that
sheriff over here i got some information
you might have and that started the
whole because they didn't really know
who
i mean the police back there was
different but that was that was the wow
not not bad mouthing any particular
agency but that was one where the news
people found that clothes that had been
thrown over the side that
cops had overlooked
they didn't
they didn't uh put the
bobby bolsole
to panga canyon guy where they killed a
guy chopped off his ear
they didn't put they wrote they wrote
something on the wall and blood there oh
they're in the cielo and then over there
by me and los feliz the the um
uh
um
they wrote in there
and
nobody nobody put them together and
manson was at the la bianca he was in
there
and then he he left like they were down
there yeah working on stuff but
i wanted that refrigerator i don't know
where it ended up the one that was the
misspelled helter skelter helter skelter
that was a good book i could ask charles
i said but he passed he was a big fan of
mine john wayne
sinatra classic rock all right
all right speaking of classic rock
number one let's get into it here
oh my god hi george
uh this is rudy salinas calling from
mission texas hey i know you're a kiss
fan uh just wanting to know
what's one of your favorite all-time
kiss songs and uh your favorite album
all right george thank you so much for
your podcast i appreciate you and the
gil and all your staff
you got some great entertainment thank
you guys bye-bye was that his name
uh oh i didn't get it i don't think he
gave it maybe
uh formation texas uh let's see were you
ever in the kiss like that you ever had
a rock
you were into the
midnighters
brothers that don't talk
uh yeah
one of them checked out too rudy rudy
rudy died this last year yeah man on his
anniversary went up to uh celebrating
his wedding anniversary went up the
hotel room a little tired and
yeah that's uh you you never know when
it's gonna now i remember watching them
when they were the solas brother little
kids over in east ely
and then
they became theater a great song great
song yes
and then they didn't talk as brothers
are they they had problems they had
personal problem between the familia
between the two brothers yeah and so
then
they split rudy stood with the group and
rudy continued to play you didn't hear
from stevie much and now stevie
is back in the fold and now he's singing
back back but i mean all those years go
by that you let sure you know oasis with
the gallagher brothers
those guys oasis great you know band and
the supersonic that that documentary is
awesome and then uh two years ago i went
to go see the who at the hollywood bowl
and that guy liam opened up no the one
that's the more of a punto than the
other one is it i think liam gallagher
is either
yeah
and he went out there and he had these
glasses on this dude he would have
he's got his hands in his pocket and he
sings kind of like this with these
glasses on and uh
he just left the stage he's like that's
all [ __ ]
that's all you [ __ ]
and he walks up and
it's like the end of the
you know nobody really claps because
they're like
hey
yeah
but he's he was great but he's got he's
one of those guys that has uh
i he's just got this [ __ ] attitude my
very british like uh yeah i always just
had some sort of chip on his shoulder
yeah i don't know
have you ever entered a show like that
that's all concerned i called the lady
at [ __ ] uh just less than a week ago
so you know what did she say
was silent
so um let's see kiss yeah let me see
i became a kiss fan when i
saw him in 1973 either don kirschner's
or in concert on abc
and then they came out with like they
had some songs
i think maybe rock and roll all night
classical it was a big one and then
they
i went to go see them as my first
concert in 1976 the forum
um i think maybe rock and roll is that
the one that i see and then i see them
now and i go which one's doing
yeah i think maybe
detroit rock city or one of those that
by the guy oh detroit rockstar about a
guy that was on the way to see the
concert and he crashed and they wrote a
song about it oh i didn't i didn't know
that's what that was so
yeah you know we were all kiss freaks
that's what they didn't call them kiss
fans they called you a kiss freak
uh so
but i stayed loyal to i stayed loyal i
said loyal to those guys uh
my whole my whole life and then i think
paul got covered oh really uh and then
they canceled some dates and then
gene got covert and uh jean's the guy
with the big language yeah he's the
tongue guy and uh
they
suspended some dates i think it's going
to be really tough for
i mean
ah man you know you're talking about you
know 12 000 14 000 people together in
the same room i mean it's it's
i mean they just had the first weekend
of college football right and it was
like i saw some 110 000 people at the
michigan michigan or michigan state
games that's the one that we only [ __ ]
joe biden
probably probably one of them what a
country
we're living in
before you could agree to disagree now
they're like they weren't recall
governor newsome [ __ ] they weren't
saying recall governor newsom all that
we'll see what happens but i mean
governor newsom only has a
a year left maybe even less than a year
or maybe a year and plus but let them
finish man
i mean it's like we have so much
it started with gray davis and it got
worse and then everybody now that is a
governor of california almost like
walking the plank man yeah like who
would want to be governor now you'd get
your back and do it again
let me in there
you know since i left everything went
into [ __ ]
i wanted to be
chief of police i really i really want
to be chief i did the interim thing in
san fernando i want to be chief of
police for city of armani
but you could there's not enough money
right now to make me chief of police
anywhere i feel sorry for the guys that
are working
because as soon as your chief of police
half the people love you have people
hate you and you're just waiting for
them to take you down
some somebody's going to go after you
sure um
on the thing you know there was a
there's a thing
it was on facebook that i saw
that uh a woman has a podcast and then
this guy was in there and he said that
he auditioned for a job as a writer on
my show and that it the the head of it
is george lopez is racist
and then this guy
who we don't remember we didn't hire
he said that um
we didn't hire him because we didn't
hire white people
and i mean all of it is a lie so you
know it's there it's gotten nobody
watching it but it's still there but
everything that that guy says is a lie
you know so i would challenge that guy i
don't know if he's watching this to come
on and uh
and tell me your story because i think
you know somebody put blatantly put lies
out there and the girl too i mean if
you're gonna have information be put out
have it even be remotely
riveted in some truth but that's that's
a lie
where did this come from what was that
it was on just a podcast you heard or
someone yeah no it's a podcast i did an
interview with a guy and he says oh and
you know 2005 i came out to la and
and i was you know i had an uh audition
to be a writer on the show and they
didn't hire me because i was white it's
like but it comes to me it doesn't
matter and it's a lie yeah but as a
matter of fact we had more white riders
if we had latinos we only had two latino
writers that's because they didn't know
how to write white writers in hollywood
i'm sure and and you know what i mean so
it's like
that stays out there
and it's a and it's a lie like i've done
a lot of stuff that that's been
you know on the line or over the line
and
somebody
so my acknowledge and some i don't but
lies are lies and that's and that's a
lie i mean i'm
yeah
so
you know i do a lot of good but that
that for that guy to say that
and
me to look at it's like that's a hundred
percent of a lie all right what else
speak on it uh all right we got another
one in the music realm
here we go
oh my god hi
hey george this is bobby g from salt
lake city utah
love your podcast
love gil carrillo
but when i think of l.a i think of the
band los lobos i was wondering if you
ever thought about having them on
anyway
good show man i listen all the time
appreciate it bye uh yes you know salt
lake city is great i you know those you
know those lovers i know i love low
lobos i just went to see him in concert
two weeks ago yeah that's right i want
to go see him two weeks did you go
backstage in silence no no no we were we
just wanted to get out of there by that
time it was late at the greek at the
greek it was a great show there
everybody i was going to go man you know
where i was in my room i didn't think i
had
i was in my south court
that there was some trouble with that
lotion
i saw my doorbell rings
they better watch out there's one door
dash guy that drives
on a hot day oh my god
someone a little guy i got
the
swimming in the pool um
yeah los lobos yeah we should we should
hit those dudes up but i know i know
those guys know them for a long time
um i have a pair of my glasses that i
got at oliver people's and i bought by
like two or three of them so i had these
black ones you know i went to a scene at
the greek years ago and uh
they're kind of caesar awards so i go i
caesar i try these on he goes oh these
are nice and so those are the ones that
jay-z wears so jay-z wears these big
daddy bees all over people's and he goes
oh these are nice i go you can have them
was what for reals because you know then
he goes i go yeah i mean they just look
perfect on him and then he goes me huh
these are the ones jc wears
[ __ ] z [ __ ]
those guys um and and now the guys even
from uh los lonely boys too man they're
good oh they're dudes they took a little
time off i think they're coming back
they let us use the song and they're
walking with herb
oh that's right i remember you talking
about that yeah and he called ringo
called me and said that they were
you know very moved by the movie and
stuff and that uh you know they want
they thank for being involved but you
know and even like that like you know
that's friends you know who did a pat
from train wrote two songs and let us
use calling all angels
um that's a relationship you know of a
friend and then and then um
the relationship with those lonely boys
but if you try to do that without having
a relationship with those guys there's a
it's an impossible thing to get music in
a movie unless you're paying up the ass
like oh yeah it's crazy expensive
yo it's like ridiculous man like if you
want to use a song
it
i don't know it could be
i mean easy like even songs that maybe
no one's heard of easy five figures like
once you're getting into if and like if
it's going to be in something you
probably want a semi-popular song anyway
it's going to cost you at least six
figures so lee greenwood wrote you know
an empire
yeah
at least so
in 2005
i had a joke
in my america's mexican special and i
was using that song and the
he wanted to know the words they said
george lopez wants to use
uh proud to be an american in his hbo
special but he wants to change the words
and then and then i had to write the
words out and then
send them to lee greenwood and he he
read them and he approved them you ready
you remember you remember to read the
words to you
that he approved okay
and i'm proud to be an american
where at least i know i'm free
can someone get these mexicans the [ __ ]
away from me yeah
[Applause]
get them all out of america
god bless the usa and he was like
yeah i could sign up to that
that was beautiful i'm so happy you sang
that thank you
he said it's better it's better when i
do it in front of but i didn't but i was
doing that just [ __ ] around and he's
like hey so what do you say no he goes
no i said yeah he loved it
yeah awesome man i love that this is a
joke yeah that is great i bet the
internet will love that like i will
speak on behalf of the internet they
will love it man
yeah so that they'll love that have fun
with that but you know part of the thing
that you know criticism of of me is
you know uh um
are they still using racist uh anti this
anti that but you have to look at where
i came i came from richard pryor i came
from george carlin um
dick gregory all those guys so when
people talk about cancel culture or
whatever i think it's almost too
late to you can't reinvent yourself or
too late that you know once
the horse hits the water change horses
because this is the way it is people
like it i saw a bunch of tickets people
that don't like it don't go
and i won't call you
i think you you're i mean your company
you your company took a lot of my money
because i used to go see i i had paid to
see at least five five six times oh
thank you
yeah there you go yeah baby all right
well uh we got a very hard hitting
question here oh go buckle up
hey yo george man coming in from san
diego uh
yeah man you know let's get right to it
man i don't know what it is man it's
like a routine for me but i'm like
a [ __ ] chronic masturbator man i
don't know what the hell is wrong with
me i don't know what's going on with me
it's it's just like what do i do man
what do i do to fix it
do i go cold turkey you know do i just
like you know [ __ ] just stop it right
away
or do i do like the alcoholic [ __ ] you
know be like kind of gradually slow down
my role you know i got a simple answer
if it ain't broken don't fix it yeah i
think
well how many what's chronic yeah
it sounded like i mean a couple times a
day he was saying
i mean
i don't know is it bad for you
if you're a crime officer lock me up
from [ __ ] as long as he's doing it to
himself and he's in private who cares i
don't care if he does it six times a day
i think when you start counting it looks
bad
yeah that's a good point
that's like six times in a day man what
the hell he's got like a very sticky
notebook that he's tracking
hand towels around
but uh um is it bad for somebody to do
that that much i mean people used to say
it was a hairy palms bad eyesight but
that was just sort of old wives tales
what is it if you're you know i know i
caught my son
you know i told him i said son stop
doing that you'll need glasses you ain't
dead i'm over here
[Laughter]
what's in the bag don't [ __ ] worry
about it yeah i was just gonna say that
um it's beautiful
yeah i you know
i i don't know man i think if you do
when you're married
at least i know when i was married that
she considered that
being unfaithful
to her really i was with myself oh man
the rules there were
not since the
[ __ ] alabama penitentiary
it was like she convicted thought crime
was awful it was pretty bad in there i'm
glad i got out 17 years so that did i
would love to hear more from this guy
hear a little bit about why he thinks
it's a problem yeah because he's got to
see the issue if he's not bothering
anybody else hey
no problem but what about medically is
medically an issue can you
can you masturbate too much medically
can you either pull a vein or
you know tell them to use lotion yeah
you get like a friction burn or
something what about this does it does
it um
does it make you
desire
things less like a woman or a person or
somebody if you're doing that all the
time if you're self satisfying yourself
does it affect your relationship you
might be having with your wife or
girlfriend or who or whoever it depends
what he's thinking about when he's
masturbating
you know i i really can't answer that
and if he thinks it's maybe a problem
well then seek professional help but if
not yeah if he's only bothered himself
there i don't see anything wrong with
him yeah if he's like masturbating about
the idea of like breaking up with his
girlfriend then maybe there's more
issues at play here
but it's
it depends as long as he's not thinking
about some little kid but he says
chronic i mean that that's got to be
high up the double digits maybe
but you don't want to be doing it by a
window you know he's going to get
hemorrhoids he's going to get right
little pebbles out of there huh
[Laughter]
well i had he didn't leave his name
either i think wisely so but uh our
message to him is what's the problem our
message is uh you know
webmd let's look at look it up and see
if there you go if it's
yeah can we look it up and see if
actually yeah i can i can check that
real quick look and see you guys vamp
for a second let me see if it's on one
day
can you masturbate too much
medically these guys man i mean
uh
in my business
these guys have great products and then
they want to come on the podcast and
you know
launch but you know this isn't a place
to launch products it's a podcast we
talk about issues so if this is you know
no offense to people i'm doing business
with but if this is part of the launch
it's not right this would be something
different you wouldn't come out here and
do a graduation speech [ __ ]
think of a better plan than
than using my our platform here to
launch [ __ ]
at the end
that's the line right there
our story
all right so uh according to health line
what what what's the website there
no no
no
here it is right here look
that's the one
oh okay that was gonna change the world
it's it's the first
mexican chocolate that takes its own
stains out of underwear
don't ask me how i did it
on your way to barstow change your
underwear don't throw them away anymore
just run them through some water and
instantly like like uh
like
hi i'm joey fix
put me down for a case right now
uh uh the guy hi it's phil swift here
and this kid said this could take
children out of your underwear with just
a little water okay what is it uh okay
uh masturbation basically despite uh
this according to healthline.com despite
the myths there are actually no physical
harmful side effects of masturbation
however excessive masturbation can harm
your relationships and other everyday
life other than that masturbation is a
fun normal and healthy activity you know
it can affect your
i had a joke where they would the doctor
said you know your psychologist says you
and your wife have to make a uh a date
night you know have it be wednesday
night and then the wife says okay don't
forget tomorrow night man it's wednesday
already yes and don't jack up don't tell
what don't tell me what not to do
don't tell me what not to do
yeah i think it's i just think it's uh
i think it's a gateway thing
it leads to
it leads to you tying up your
your levels you know and
doing stuff to yourself putting them
carrot in your cuda one of those you
know
right and i'm putting it back in the
market
but carrying your hula gives you better
vision
it'll open your eyes up for sure
what else do we have all right and you
know we've had some pretty good guests i
think you know uh anna nabarro was great
oscar was amazing and then oscar getting
the copy so we want everybody to be safe
and wish oscar and we wish him the best
wishing the best good health absolutely
uh i was trying to see if i if i can get
an answer from him
you know i i wanted to make
on i
i posted something on instagram you know
wishing well it was great yeah yeah and
i wanted to send him a personal message
hey i have a big pair of consoles
waiting for you to come out
but right now may not be a time when
he's ready for a a funny line you know
yeah
okay he's better he's better uh
he's still a little bit weak but he's
feeling better
good that's great
we'd love to hear that
what is that rubbed uh ironical okay
that's my humorous backpack but i'm
still a little bit better okay good
good
yeah [ __ ] maybe i got a shot at him then
uh hey uh
yeah
good manny so we heard from oscars he's
good good awesome little follow-up uh
you guys want another yeah all right
thrown back to the george lopez show
days here
george huge fan i know you hear that a
lot but i had a question
um what was your favorite scene to shoot
for the george lopez show a huge fan of
that show thanks for watching with my
mom
thank you
um
wow well first of all i mean all of it
was kind of uh
all it was kind of
a bit of a
nobody ever thought even myself you know
never thought that it would you know i
told you about that thing in the paper
um
not thinking we'd get past four then
nine then
you know a full season
but i think all in all you know i knew
that it took 88 episodes to get into
syndication
so i remember the president of warner
brothers told me
at about like 13
because i had an issue i went to him
directly amanda mann
and he said that i could either be a
crazy actor
and think everybody was out to get me or
i could go back and go to work
and i said i'll go back and go to work
but that guy legitimately turned out to
be detrimental to the show he's not the
president of warner brothers tv anymore
but it didn't sound like he had the best
bedside manner based on that
conversation he was uh
you know we sold the reboot to netflix
and he he squashed it
uh maybe five years ago so when people
ask me oh you know you should reboot
your show we were way ahead of it and
this guy uh
legitimately made a point
not have the reboot
uh ever happen was that was there any
sort of rationale or he's just someone
who had approvals and he said no no i
think yeah i just think he he never
really was a fan of the show i think you
know we he got to a point where
it was it was doing well and i mean he
pretended to be a fact i mean that's
kind of what the thing is he pretended
to be a fan of the show but then in
reality he said you know if you guys go
and sell this you know have him come
back and let's talk and we did and it
was like it's not going to happen and so
so the guy who told you like don't don't
think everyone is out to get you was in
fact a guy who was he wasn't you that's
what you know
smile at your face all the time they
want to take your place backstab that's
right so he was responsible for that but
i think the one the um
let's see that was 88 i wore a dale
jared's uh nascar jersey in the show
so on 88 so i could always tell when 88
was but i think you know
the ones that sandra were in because of
she was such a big influence on the show
and like really happened because of her
so to see her
on that set with me and her and knowing
how
it just started from just like hey come
on let's sit down and see if you know
what we got here to from that to all of
that and even now i was on the doctor
it's on
this morning it was on
it's i watch it it'll be forever it was
a great show then
it's a great show now yeah and i still
watch that's still a good sign of the
yeah it'll be on forever
when i'm gone it'll still be it'll scoop
you around thank god
um i kind of want to ask the flip side
of that which was were there any
episodes or scenes that ended up being
like unexpectedly brutal or something
crazy happened on the day or last minute
or anything like that um
let's see i think we did we early on we
did a show where the guy was right
around 9 11 i think after the beginning
of the show that the guy was it turned
out to be a guy that was on that show
claws and he was in a few center both
movies uh
um
like the recent jason altoon uh yeah on
uh jason
and
he was a arab employee that had taken
flight lessons
and we worked in an airplane parts
factory and my mom
was profiling him as a
terrorist and then
she brought him we took him to dinner
and he came to dinner she's trying to
grill him
and then she says uh
oh i love to he goes i love to fly and
see the pyramids and he goes oh it goes
no in vegas you know right by the paris
hotel and the mgm there's a period and
then
the mom looked at me and she goes am i
the only ones whose eyebrows are raised
and i said yeah because you drew them on
like that
uh but yeah you know those those things
you know and then i remember the i
remember the
the guy warner brothers the guy was in
the note says warner brothers does not
want to do this show
because it was about something that it
was a comedy about something that had
really happened and
that episode right or your time on your
show in general and you know
i fire i think i fired him
in the end of the show
but going back
i wish i hadn't fired him like i i we
want a couple of awards for the show but
i wish i would have believed them but i
think they made me in the writing of it
they made me let him go
where i wish i would have said i believe
that i believe that what he's telling me
is true
and if and we're just profiling him like
we profile other people but
that was one that
i mean the other guy you know i come up
with the idea with my partner
and then he took his name off the script
oh really and it was just me and then
you know warner brothers doesn't want to
do it he took his name off the script
all of a sudden you look at
the episode and it says written by where
before it had like five names that was
just my name
and you're like are you [ __ ]
that says only george
and then he wants some awards from them
to stand up that that's right yeah and i
said we're still doing it and i i i like
the show
yeah well like for people who are
familiar taking your name off a script
is a big deal a huge deal because it's
in perpetuity like you know those things
they air i'm not even sure that affects
your money i'm not sure if even that
that particular episode i could see how
that particular episode would not see
the light of day
uh these days because of what's going on
yeah i've heard you know i've heard of
people pulling episodes and wakes up
like school shootings and stuff like
that similar sort of piece and we did a
school we did school shootings there on
the show we did
steroids
uh stacy keach was my boyfriend's my
daughter's boyfriend's father he was
great stacy keach is [ __ ] amazing i
can't believe i got stacey keach to be
him that guy man such a great great
actor man to this day my wife makes fun
of me because i used to call him stacy
keach
what is it i don't know it's casey
stitch
stacy keach yeah stitch oh yeah yeah
and i had it backwards
yeah i mean
we had some pretty good actors on there
man and you know the thing about my show
was if i i was going to all these laker
games and if i saw somebody at a laker
game
i would say to do my show
uh nice um
ma the guy from the green mile who's my
buddy what's it uh big guy yeah i'm a
man he passed
oh what is his name uh michael clark
duncan yes
you know i saw michael clark duncan
and i asked him to be on the show and
then i asked everybody if they golf
and he said he didn't go off and then i
think he was dating amarosa back then
and he started to golf and he really
liked it man like he i remember he came
to the tournament with her and they
played brother riviera
and um we'd see him at the games and me
and mine would take mayan and he was a
really really sweet dude man and he had
a
heart attack and passed really young you
know and and uh he did an episode where
he was like a ghetto dentist
and you went to go see me had a do-rag
on because i was trying to get a better
dental plan for uh uh my husband my
kidney the braces and i went in there
and the two brothers were like what's
wrong with our dentist and you go in
there
and he and i get into it about whose
childhood was worse
you know he goes my mother my mom used
to put me in the closet she would go
party and do it like that i said oh yeah
well my neighbor touched me and
appropriated my no notes
[Music]
and then my wife goes no that's that's a
lag i managed to win it [ __ ] i
lied but him and dog the bounty hunter
oh yeah it was on where he was the
neighbor he grabbed my jacket and tore
my jacket
i tried i'm trying to walk off no way
and i said as i walk off you know
grabbed me he had this jacket on [ __ ]
come back he [ __ ] tore it oh my god i
could throw the collar to the sleeve and
he didn't do anything but just grab me
man that was the same one viewer ghost
was in uh he made a comeback uh dog yeah
because he was off the air for a long
time he said he got the n word pass
there is no n word faster they use the n
where he goes yeah i got a pass from who
yeah you'll have to show me the dots
yeah they're gone that you can't get a
pass for that um but uh
anybody that i saw who else barbara eden
i dream of genie batman genie batman was
on he was a lawyer oh
he was great my dream of jamie was bad
she actually she her too
wait like adam west batman
and then everybody had them signing
batman stuff and he comes in the back
here he goes george
listen old chump
i feel like i'm a bit at a convention
i'd like to not i'm coming back next
week and i want to come back but
i don't want any i don't want to be able
to have a look at this like
i'm signing things all day so i said all
right we got it yeah try to tell how to
tell everybody stop getting into the
sign [ __ ] i said you [ __ ] batman
but he was a he was quite older too man
i think he was in his 90s
but he
he was um
and he did my talk show he did a thing
where the batmobile oh man wow i bet his
whole life has felt like a convention
since he was batman and even though they
made batman's i mean still he was the
one that
he couldn't fly he was the only one that
was real he's the only one that was real
and then and that hole where they used
the bat caves over there by if i went
hiking i'd go look for it about my house
is that right they would come down yeah
and i would be like where is that thing
and if you look in uh look it up right
there it's not far from my house man and
i still want to go see it but i don't
know for what you [ __ ] oreo it's a
[ __ ] hole in the probably go there's
nothing throwing each other in there
you know what i mean they're probably in
there
i can tell you to come out though
with a closed eye
call me barrooka
yeah look so bronson bronson canyon in
atlanta
uh in griffith park here come here you
go in there and cool out in there
look at that yeah
some people are looking at
straight in uh yeah in griffith park uh
known as the filming location for many
films and tv series especially westerns
and science fiction i'm going in there
all good are we good what else uh i got
one more a little fun one to end on
how's that
this is good all these are good huh the
recaps we'll get somebody in there who
else yeah these are again call in keep
leaving voices
i'm doing some infomercials 818
you didn't know she was on until the
motorcycle went by i was just passing
gas in case my wife's watching yeah hey
listen we're gonna go back to third
grade we'll go back pass back
[Laughter]
all right one more
they had the world hey it's me from san
diego hey man i gotta ask
what happens
when the aliens find find the land down
on uh earth man you know i mean what
what goes through people's minds
when they see the martians come down the
ufos
what is the first thing
that happens in your opinion
you know he goes on for a little bit
just feed him fentanyl
yeah i leave him some cookies with a
fentanyl in them yeah
man where do you guys stand on aliens
are you
believers truthers there's something out
there i believe that there's something i
don't care about it i got enough problem
with the people down here well what
about that's a great what about all the
spirits in my house like
i mean yeah they were they're not there
anymore but you take down that painting
yet the the one of you the one looks
like the devil on your wall i know but
you know that
that was not uh like i live alone man i
mean
that was really something the orbs and
the words alone alone
yeah
just me and my little loubouderman
you know i make it look like i eat clam
chowder
but i just ordered
you'll be like
got that red lobster
you know i try to you know i try to make
it look like i at least civilize because
you have the same lady coming to the
house you know she knows a lot of
different sights and smells
[Applause]
can't deal with some spirits of her own
it's like you know i'm driving the car
it's like oh my [ __ ] towel is in the
bedding
try to go back it's like while o.j
dropped the [ __ ] glove man you're
like [ __ ] i dropped the boat
[ __ ] me it's got my [ __ ] dna all over
it's all crunchy [ __ ] gloves like
this man
it's like in home alone
you could put it back on this thing was
all
with my metabolic gotta
with whipped cream on top
a dark brown towel with a grandma you
could use your i'll be out next week you
can use your towel as a scraper for your
titanic man
have you left that my hand talai
during like
uh uh when the mosquitoes are out like
you just take it to where there's bad
mosquitoes like north carolina
and you you put it out there in the
middle of the street the next day they'd
be like i'm gonna thank you and we
trying to get rid of this
100 years
they're all on that towel that that
sound [ __ ] i don't know what you use on
there man but it's they're all gone we
want some back
it's killing the
fauna in our in our town that's my
special recipe
man bad
oh my god you have to pretend it's other
things you know to not look so socially
yeah
so aliens
so so
i don't know man there's there's it
won't be good that's my is there a
slender man you believe
that they're slenderman they they put
out the
they're now putting out ufos exist
you know they're saying
you know what
so and they've been watching you there's
been ufos since the 50s that old black
and white where the guy's like what the
[ __ ] is that and they're going you can
see it
um and they and they are releasing more
information so
so
something's out there i call them ufos
so the ufos are out there but i don't
give a [ __ ] you know alien that's
there's like i said i got enough
problems right here but listen
if they ever come down and want to take
someone up and [ __ ] them and then run
tests on them there's a guy in san diego
that would be the prime candidate he's a
volunteer
[Laughter]
he'll give you a dna sample
all right thanks
all right
that's good great that does it for today
keep leaving voicemails and keep leaving
voicemails and uh
what are we getting into um
anything to plug upcoming dates or
anything no no
but but you know let's let's talk about
what uh let's talk about
if you leave messages about
what it's been like to be in covet like
i mean if you've unfortunately lost
people who
who have yeah uh let's talk about the
how your how the life how the maybe that
your lives are impacted now
well regular regular people not not me
you know because i still travel but
what's it like on the day
on the ground you know on a daily basis
i don't know i lost uh within a month i
lost two brother-in-laws you know from
it i lost my compadre and his brother
who i went you know
i grew up with his brother we went to
school together we went to vietnam you
know where we did everything together
then this guy got his
stuff together he got a life together
and
he became a uh
construction guy had his own business
got his license got everything
everything he needed
he's remodeled my house and him and his
brother died within two weeks of each
other and what happened man they just
they got it they got it you know and and
and my compass which was his older
brother sat there and said you know what
i watched my younger brother suffer when
he would they wondered i'm not going to
do that i'm not going to put me on this
i'm not going to
let it take its course you know and he
was in the hospital and he he called me
up just a few days before he died
and
we had a talk
you know and he was just saying i'm just
i'm not going to give up coppa you know
i'm here and yeah
it was all good and i thought he was
going to come out of it did he get
vaccinated uh i don't know if he was
vaccinated you know i listen i mean
that's a choice but was it before the
vaccine
no no the vaccine was out and and so
i don't know i i really don't know if he
got
vaccinated
i know he did not want to suffer like
his brother and he said he was finally
said i'm not going to do it and that was
it and this guy was
one of the toughest guys i knew i mean
he he was from the body
company i'm here i'm there
and i remember i stopped some guy you
know an old pico guy with a gun
he said look about you know you're
always telling me hey call the cops look
at that guy and he's walking down the
street with a rifle
so i went out there i said hey what's
happening holmes hey you know who i am
he says oh yeah he says you know my
canal i said yeah i know you're looking
out that's a good looking gun you got
there you might him i see it
and he let me see it he said i said is
it loaded he says no i say you know what
i what i do for a living he says no
i said i'm the huda brother
and so let's see if it's loaded and it
started
started ejecting i said you know what
you're not getting this gun back
and i said what do you mean he looks at
me so what do you mean i'm not getting
that gun back
that's my gun i'm taking that
and my company was right there he says
hey look he's a cop he's got to go by
the law i don't i'll kick your [ __ ]
ass right now wow
i'm i'm from the barrio brother i'll
kick your [ __ ] ass right now i told
my wife
i had already told her call the cops
called
the station
she yelled where was he going he was
just walking through the walking dead
he picked the gun up from one house and
was now walking through the hood from
someplace else
and i knew it was i knew the house that
it came from
oh wow so i got the gun
his homeboy came and said let it go
brother let it go
i got the gun i took it
down to the
the kid the guy that he took from this
house i took it down
to his dad's house
and i said here here you are
here's the gun this is what happened
that's what i got and he says thank you
miho he said but next time [ __ ] him
don't give him a break take the gun take
him break the [ __ ] gun take them all
to jail i don't give a [ __ ] this is
[ __ ] wrong
yeah and so that's that's the way it was
this is my company he was a tough one
when my when my wife's brother we're all
camping together lake nacimanto here
like at that time he had a little
travison sun
and
sun's getting in trouble my
brother-in-law is yelling at him and
michael
is right there saying [ __ ] him up go
[ __ ] him up don't let him get away with
that [ __ ] wow and and so
that's the kind of guy he was
had the heart of gold when they shot
tom coleman a deputy from east valley
station got killed while on patrol
my copa called my house right away
because it just said deputy shot yeah
died no name
called my house i answered the phone
he cried on the phone
he said i was just checking
if it was you it's not you
he says and let me tell you right now i
don't give a [ __ ] what happens i'd
rather visit you in jail than i would
visit you at the cemetery
that's how much i love you but you do
what you got to do to stay alive that's
amazing and and so
and he died at covet right after buddy
says his brother was marine my buddy
that grew up with he was a hardcore
marine vietnam veteran
everything so i know a lot of people i i
won't say a lot i know several people
including family members
that have passed from it
it was their time
man
it's awful it was their time
all right let's uh yeah if you got
stories if you're talking about mel's
beautiful man
but
it's it's a tough thing it's a tough
thing to see
have relationships that long and
and have to see it go oh it is go like
that it is the guy that broke me in
homicide
the guy that taught me everything i know
that made me
the good homicide investigator that i
was
i was the best man at two out of three
of his weddings
two out of three of his marriages
i did more [ __ ] with this guy we got
more
he was just a great guy and had a heart
of gold
the last marriage lasted 25 years until
he died he was a great one she's a great
lady
but
don garcia passed away from covet
that's probably one of the only adult
males when they told me i cried yeah i
cried and then she just recently gave me
a pillow
and the pillow
is a hawaiian shirt
that don garcia wore oh
and there's a
wow
tear me up there there's a message on
there that said he wore this
and
we both cried together when she gave it
to me because
uh
she wanted me to have this man that's
it's that's really something though i
think it's a it's a great gift oh i was
gonna help you give to give somebody
something like so thoughtful
made me
cry love the lady god bless me
if momo goes we'll make comforters
that's the note we needed
all right thanks everyone that's what
hit the show
you